stephen hawking un astrophysicien
vraiment une
avec son physique singulier saha voit
désormais célèbre et surtout son esprit
pour résumer c'est le einstein
contemporain quand on lui diagnostique
là et celle à 20 ans on lui donne deux
années havre son corps c'est un met son
intelligence brille sa passion ce sont
les trous noirs ils poussent leurs
connaissances un niveau jamais atteint
on a toujours cette représentation des
trous noirs qui gobent de la matière
mais dont ne rien ne ressent finalement
et lui a proposé qu au contraire non les
trous noirs pouvaient émettre de la
réalisation et enfin à la limite
s'évaporer
décoré de plusieurs médailles mais pas
du prix nobel car sa théorie n'a jamais
été observé il a conquis des millions de
lecteurs avec sa brève histoire du temps
et s'ils étaient autant apprécié c'est
aussi grâce à son humour personnes ces
derniers travaux stephen hawking les
amener avec le seul muscles delajoux qui
lui permettait de communiquer et pour
ajouter une couche extraordinaire
stephen hawking est né un 8 avril
l'anniversaire de la mort de galilée et
il est mort un 14 mars
l'anniversaire de naissance d'albert
einstein si mathieu prost radio canada
min
[Musique]